[Music]
Charles first of all congratulations on
the sport Emmy
thank you my brother I appreciate it a
lot of people work hard at Turner Sports
I appreciate them do you ever get any
feedback when you're you're negative
about the NBA playoffs aren't any good
or you might be critical of you know
truTV or any of that does anybody ever
say Charles can you ease up a little bit
here uh no because they million players
haven't been good I think Dan the fans
aren't stupid well I mean some of them
are the most fans are they knowledgeable
they know that we've only had last night
let's just only the second game in this
round that was decided by less than
double digits my fans aren't stupid they
they they know this thing has not been
good and I've said it for the last
couple years if we keep making these
super teams we're going to have the fans
gonna there's going to be a backlash I
mean you think about it between guys
resting and we know who's going to be in
the finals every year there's going to
be a backlash at some point how much
criticism do you get James Harden on
last night's performance you know I you
have to eat in play well for a couple
reasons I want to get to turn the ball
over but he was just holding a ball to
try to make the office at the score like
in the last five seconds of the game it
was really weird changes played great
all year but for some reason last night
and maybe it was on the coast they only
played seven players I'm going to even
remember that ever happened in the NBA
we're a team in the playoffs only play
seven players so maybe he got tired
because you know he's going against
Kawhi Leonard who's probably the best
offender in the world and then that
Simmons kids plays fantastic so he might
have been tired but I just got
frustrated like they just held the ball
the last five minutes of the game in the
last five minutes of all the time they
would just hold the ball that was five
seconds to go in the clock and then try
to make
something miraculous happened if this
was another player would we be more
critical of that player this was Russell
Westbrook er Steph Curry or LeBron James
who did that last night
would we be more critical today yes
you know remember guys are being killing
Russell Westbrook for the last several
years when he was in that same situation
but you know what it was a it finally
got a decent game that but but man the
gossipers you know Danny Green my man
Ginobili they made great plays down the
stretch but I was just excited to get a
good game because the playoffs of this
one they haven't been very good Charles
Barkley joining us Dan Patrick show we
were talking about the best trio in NBA
history at their peak
we were talking about magic Kareem and
worthy even though Kareem wasn't at his
peak then bird McHale Parrish LeBron
Wade Bosh Jordan Pippen Rodman Pierce
Garnett Allen although I don't think any
of those were at their peak curry Durant
Thompson Duncan Parker and Manu if you
were starting a team and I said you
could pick that trio of those on that
list who would you pick well if my
memory is I don't remember everything I
mean without being first over there you
can't put I'm not even in that
conversation because I was like a rookie
two years after the the the Sixers won a
championship so I wasn't any good and
dr. Moses were past their prime probably
the closest guys in their prime would be
Byrd McHale and parish the greatest
front line ever you know they're right
there you know Michael and Scottie and
Harvick Horace Grant were terrific and I
think that Horace Grant never really
nobody ever mentioned him because he was
just quiet but he was great and she
never dinner on him he's a better
all-around player to Dennis Rodman yes
this was clearly a better rebounder
always was an underrated defender and he
was a clearly a much better
score up and because I tell he was on to
read it
but Dennis obviously is a great
rebounder but magic and worthy were at
their peak even though Kareem was on the
tail end he was he was still he could
still he was still going to score if you
got it into him
yeah but he was he was past his prime
worthy and obviously magic and worthy
worth terrific but cream was he's
probably almost forty at some doing one
of their to one of their rings probably
so the magic and where they were in
their Primerica James won MVP if I
remember correctly if I said LeBron Wade
and Bosh magic cream and worthy is
LeBron and magic a push yeah yeah LeBron
you know upset this uh nobody's ever
gonna get in my top five stop saying
that we stop saying that because it's
LeBron wins two more he doesn't get in
your top five you crazy I put I put in
past Kobe well you guys you guys make me
laugh you guys about us guys who's us
guys well because you guys are always
talking about champion children so how
does LeBron just get to supersede Kobe
if Kobe got to more championships like I
said if Kobe wins in the LeBron win one
one or two more maybe one if they beat
the Warriors this year I might move in
Pasco P listen I'm always cool I've
always said Michael Oscar Kareem Bill
Russell and will those are my five
greatest and that's never gonna change
you can now Kobe LeBron those guys are
on our they're five and they're six and
seven but I always laugh I hear these
guys cook you ton of waters LeBron work
ring first of all he is amazing he's
amazing but y'all always talk about how
many championship guys won Kobe's got
five championship with a less LeBron
with another one I'm going to keep them
at number seven back
Colby that's the only way that he can
pass Kobe is if he wins another time
that's what you gotta be telling me well
Noah ganas are you value that you know
how many championships did Wilt
Chamberlain win but he won one you know
but the problem is a bit lost a war on
one but he averaged a triple-double how
the guys don't win MVP because he has a
triple-double and in fairness to whip
salmon you know what Tim Lynch in arrest
to me a bother to most underrated
players of all the time because in
everybody said he only wanted one I
think gee everyone to and will want to I
think but they lost in the finals to
build it lost to Bill Russell like 12
years in a row and there's no state
there's no shame when we look at the
bill Rocco in the finals I mean they
were loaded does he um picked four
here's here's a question for you do you
think we wondered this if I ancillary
bird who's the greatest Celtic of all
time would bird say himself or Bill
Russell I think he said Bo Russell yeah
I do too well but what he think that he
was the greatest of all time the
greatest Celtic of all time he would
just know be respectful no I think you
got to give me think about a Bill
Russell I only know what he did in high
school
but he won in college I think he won two
in college and he wanted 11 in the NBA
that's self-explanatory he's the
greatest Celtics ever no question even
asked I don't even think it's close you
get if you went listen you have more
rings and fingers you in all
conversation on the best to do anything
he should add a finger him and Phil
Jackson should add a finger and can you
let stick around I want to ask you about
this new show called American race can
you do that sure all right welcome back
Emmy winner Charles Barkley in fact once
they announced that he had won a Sports
Emmy last night I think Kenny Smith
downst-- you with champagne is that
right yeah man I'm in here for
what if shack boy to you huh would have
Shack did it to you would you punched
into oh he dearly he did it to me also
yeah and that's like the second time
he's done it call me off-guard last
night jack is getting bigger in neutral
sack just a big boo bear which am I see
way how many spins is he like three and
a half spins oh oh no you need to spin a
harder
you see 350 or see more than that it
water no man
I couldn't imagine taking a charge from
him he's a big dude man is a big dude
is anybody bigger like Mark Eaton was a
big guy who else does anybody come close
to Shaq as far as size goes Martine is
probably the biggest guy who's up was
big and thick I mean obviously we've had
Mutombo who's just tall and lanky where
my loophole was tall and lanky but mark
even is the but man you know you look at
guys you know I tell people you look at
guys like MB Bill Walton aghast cos big
guys like seven 172 in the notion that
Shaquille O'Neal could stay healthy for
20 years is one of the most physically
amazing things because Shaq is from day
one he was humongous and for him to be
able to play double-digit years in the
NBA I think you played 20 and never get
hurt he got hurt in everybody gets hurt
at the end but for him to be able to
play and not and stay healthy is one of
the most amazing things I've ever seen
you have a new show on TNT it's called
American race and being it really
excited about it alright you've never
shied away we've always had great
conversations you look at both sides or
three sides or four sides whatever it is
but what is it about this show that you
want people to know well if you know
first of all there's some so you know I
got some critics who are full of it who
say things about me there's not true you
know I said some positive thing
about the cops in the past so my critics
try to say that I think it's alright to
kill black unarmed black men and then
I'm for police brutality so that's one
thing I want to come out I'm not full
police brutality I'm not for police
killing unarmed black man
so my traitors need to stop trying to
make their name on me
you have my critics you have no talent
so the way for you to get people to
click and listen to us opaque shot to me
so let that misnomer go I'm not police
brutality in any form whatsoever
secondly we in the black community we
lead the cops because some our wounds
are self-inflicted we have to start
treating each other with more respect
and dignity they got to stop killing
each other that's one thing that I hope
come out of the show but what the first
show is from Baltimore is really about
the relationship between the black
community and the cops and I try to
examine that one episode is about the
Muslim ban and one episode is about
undocumented immigrants so I'm doing
what I was meant to do start a dialogue
and a conversation some people don't
like it which I hope they do some people
don't dislike it we still get over that
too I'm going to mean I'm not going to
worry about my critics or what other
people think I'm just gonna keep trying
to do positive things playing example
before I let you go I saw where lunch of
all shoes are 495 what did your shoes go
for when you were playing I don't think
my shoes have a guy I think made it $200
at the top in or close to it I don't
know the exact number but I think close
to 200 at some point when I was at the
peak of my my talents but that might
translate to about 400 dollars in
today's dollars I would not let Nike
sell my shoes before
hundred dollars uh Michael Jordan
probably should have the highest price
tag on shoes
because number one but not now not just
what he did you got to think about this
Dan nobody was selling shoes until
Michael came alone
there was no individual shoes I mean so
Michael always make the most money not
just because he had great shoes and they
can make a great product but think about
there's guys making a hundred million
dollars a year because of Michael Jordan
I mean so he should always have the
highest price shoes they put it because
he he made it good for everybody
nobody had a signature shoe before
Michael Jordan so that's why he should
always have because he made all of us a
lot of money he's Charles Barkley you
can tune in tonight and tomorrow night
at 9:00 and 10:00 Eastern it's called
American race Charles again
congratulations on another sports Emmy
and good luck with the show thank you my
brother your guys creaky so keep up the
great work that's Charles Barkley the
Dan Patrick show weekday mornings on
audience